thanks for joining us America we're so
glad that you are here Jeff is with us
in Phoenix Arizona hi Jeff how are you
great sir pleasure speaking with you you
too what's up just quick note my wife
and I had a great time at the smart
conference here in whew finished a few
weeks ago so thanks for putting that
together it was a great time thank you
very much it was a great day
how can I help well I think I know what
direction you would go on this but I
wanted confirmation or some motivation
and my wife and I were on our last bill
and baby step two which is a vehicle
cool and we got this vehicle back in
March and we know it's on the high end
but we paid fifty thousand for it and
over the last seven months we've paid
$15,000 extra towards it which leaves us
about thirty five thousand dollars left
but I got a little buyer's remorse right
now a little bit into it because we're
on our last step
excuse me and so I'm just trying to
figure out whether whether I should just
bite the bullet and ride this together
if we should jettison it and move on to
our next or next phase and baby step
three
what's your household income we're
looking at roughly maybe 140 hundred and
fifty this year and what's the other car
worth the other car is worth probably
twenty twenty-five someone there okay
well generally a good rule of thumb is
to not have vehicles things with motors
in them all the things that you own with
motors in them totaling up more than
half your annual income because they're
going down in value and you got too much
of your world financially tied up in
something going backward so you're right
on that bubble is what you're describing
to me what kind of car is this Toyota
pickup truck mmm okay and Kelly Kelly
Blue Book estimates a value of roughly
46 okay all right so it must be just
coal what is a Titan completely maxed
out it's got this leather you know
moonroof you name it it's it's it's a
nice one yeah fifty thousand dollar
truck I mean they're out there I mean I
got a raptor they run that
Wow okay I didn't I didn't I just didn't
know Toyota had a product run that high
that's interesting okay over here in
peace we got the Bronco Billy a package
so that's really not on it okay you did
you got everything every Bell and
whistle available well if you love it
and you'll go ahead and pay a price to
get rid of it it's not completely out of
line it's close its close it's not
enough that I got to yell at you and go
you have to Sally all right but if you
really really like the truck and it's
something you really worked hard you
wanted to get it and so forth I mean
that's fine and you know it's but again
just as a rule of thumb going forward if
you're making a hundred and a half you
don't want any more than 75 tied up in
rolling stock yes sir because it's just
all going the wrong way you know that
thing's gonna be worth 25 when you blink
your eyes twice you know well that's
that's kind of what's hitting me in the
face - and then the other thing is you
know if we get rid of it and I take the
cash the extra fifteen and we put into
it now I've obviously lost part of that
and then what am I going to you know I'm
gonna have something paid off it'll be
you know the the complete opposite of
what I got just you just gotta be you
know is it worth cutting your lifestyle
really deep to get rid of this
thirty-five thousand dollars really
really fast if it's worth that to you
that's fine your again you're right on
the bubble any more expensive or any
less income and it wouldn't make any
sense at all so you you know it's a rule
of thumb I used it's not exact it's not
perfect but the concept is you know in
your life after this purchase the next
time you get ready to buy something just
make sure you're keeping a small
percentage of your income in things that
are going down in value and a large
percentage of your income in things that
are going up in value that's how people
get rich versus get poor so that's where
you want to be long term so if you like
it enough to fight to fight through the
data and get rid of it and then just
make sure next time you do this that
you're a little bit more conservative
than this
[Music]
you
[Applause]
[Music]